un show fatri notre folle en deux jours
kamba de céline nous sommes chez sas
bensouda dans le sud ouest d'ottawa au
sein des branches d'arbres ont traversé
le toit et le plafond les orages
violents du 21 mai ont laissé sa maison
dans un piteux état bon une histoire par
chedjou le père de famille a procédé à
des travaux d'urgence le lendemain il
fallait boucher les trous laissés par
des branches pour éviter d'autres dégâts
draft aux tories bild on
doit murs et plafonds devront être
remplacés sans compter les dommages
causés à la structure
[Musique]
en ce moment des travaux qui pourraient
prendre tout l'été selon monsieur bîmes
sudan mais il devra attendre avant de
commencer les travaux parce que le
milieu de la construction et frappés par
une autre tempête politique des
matériaux des terribles depuis depuis 12
16 mois environ il ya une demande de
l'estimé de plus d'une main d'oeuvre
qualifiée qui est pas disponible puis
une augmentation du coût cela c'est la
tempête par shop son entreprise se
spécialise en développement du bâtiment
au québec et en ontario
après les orages violents les appels ont
doublé et on multiplie les réparations
temporaires on avait déjà
eu
tort
puis ces sites mobiles selon toi et
automne de 10,3 ceux qui vont rester
temporaire mais
les paris de la riva
poken explique
cet autre entrepreneur avertit aussi que
les délais seront plus longs il a reçu
400 appels et 200 demandes en ligne
après les orages
n'est plus premier arrivé premier servi
explique-t-il son équipe priorise
maintenant les besoins les plus urgents
de quoi mettre à l'épreuve la patience
des clients ici rosalie 5 la radio
canada ottawa